the budget for Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny is reported to have
reached nearly 300 million dollars
making it the most expensive film in the
Indiana Jones franchise as well as one
of the most expensive films ever made
hitting eighth on the list surpassed
only by big budget Pirates and superhero
films the biggest Factor behind this
huge budget is likely the use of deep
fake technology if you look at the
budgets of previous Indiana Jones movies
or even all of lucasfilm's movies it
tops the list by a huge margin with some
estimates placing the cost of D aging
Harrison Ford at up to a hundred million
dollars there are several other factors
that contributed to the film's high
budget besides the Deep thick technology
though one of them is the salary of
Harrison Ford who reportedly earned 65
million dollars for Israel making him
one of the highest paid actors in
Hollywood